My wife thinks that she may have a bladder infection. She has to get up several times a night to urinate.
There is sometimes a follow order order.
She has pain or she has no pain or other symptoms.
What's a good supplement to take to help support her bladder health?
Thank you for your help.
If you think that you have a bladder infection, many times the first sign of a bladder infection is just increase your radiation.
Lots of people with bladder infections have no pain.
It's interesting to know as people age, like in your 70s, 80s, 80s or 80s, many times the only symptom to a bladder infection is abnormal thought patterns.
The abnormal behavior, so in a geriatric population, you'll just see someone kind of out of it, kind of talking gibberish, talking like what's matter with this person.
First thing you need to suspect is a hidden UTI.
Many times they don't have any urinary issues.
As a younger person, urinary issues may be the first sign.
Different orders of the urine can be a sign that can be more a sign of Candida type issues, especially if it's an EST order.
But what would you do about it if you suspect it?
First of all, it's good to get a culture.
You can even get your old urinary dip sticks on Amazon, and you can test whether you have bacteria in your urine or go to the doctor and get a UA to see if you have bacteria in the urine.
If you do have bacteria in the urine, they're going to recommend a culture, which would be the most appropriate thing.
Sometimes doctors will just reach for their pad and give out a prescription for an antibiotic.
If you're so inclined to not want to do antibiotics and want to do a natural approach, things like D-Mannos, which is a sugar, can be extremely helpful for urinary tract infections.
If you look at our store, to get to our store, you can go to cuttersclinic.com, the upper right-hand corner of the website, you'll see shop or store.
Click on that and you'll go to our store, and you can search urinary tract infections or search D-Mannos, M-A-N-O-S-E.
We have several products that are high-dose, D-Mannos, that are specifically for UTIs.
We also have specific products for Candida. So if you search for Candida in yeast infections, you'll see different products.
Because if it's a Candida, you do want to treat it a little bit differently. D-Mannos can help with that as well.
But treating it to rebalance the flora can be something you need to address as well.
Candida is an imbalance in flora. Usually it's not just affecting the UTI, it's usually affecting the gut, and getting some balance in your microbiotic can be beneficial.